Hello, and welcome to this Visual Studio Code VS
code crash course where you are going to learn all
the ins and outs of the best and most popular
and most powerful editor for web development.
My name is James q quick, and I run a YouTube
channel at James q quick on YouTube, where I
do web development tutorials every week. So you
can go and check that out if you're interested.
In the meantime, let's go ahead and get started
breaking down all of the ins and outs of VS
code in this crash course. So before we dive
in, and actually show you what VS code looks
like and what it's all about, I want to start by
just kind of talking about what it's about. So
Visual Studio code is in my mind, the most popular
and most powerful text editor there is, especially
in the realm of web development. So if you look
at what VS code is, it's not a fully fledged IE
or integrated development environment.
It's not like Eclipse is for Java or
IntelliJ is for Java or for Visual Studio is
for C sharp and Windows related activities.
Visual Studio code is more of a lightweight text
editor. So you can compare this to something like
atom or brackets or notepad plus plus etc.
The really cool thing about VS code is that
it's cross platform, which means it runs on Mac,
Windows and Linux. And you can see here, it's got
a download button that says download for Mac for
me, because it's automatically detecting which
operating system I'm currently on. Now, some
of the cool behind the scenes stuff of why
that's possible is VS code is actually built with
something called electron j s. So electron j s
allows you to build desktop applications using
web technologies, JavaScript, HTML, and CSS,
which is really, really neat. So VS code, I think,
is one of the best examples of how you can build a
really powerful and really performant application
that can do a lot of things that you'll learn
more about here in a few minutes with your basic
web technology. So electron is really amazing in
that sense. And that allows VS code to now be
cross platform, which means regardless of what
operating system you're on, you can download VS
code and you can start working with it from there.
So I kind of mentioned vs. Code is I would say,
the most popular text editor in web development,
which means it's great for doing HTML, CSS,
JavaScript, doing react, or node or PHP or Python,
things like that. But it can do a lot more than
just those languages. It can it can work with
Java, it can work with C sharp, it can work
with dotnet core, it can work with markdown,
for example, we might see a little bit
of that in this crash course as well.
You can work with almost anything inside of VS
code. And that's the real power behind it, where
it's really lightweight, it's super fast to
start up. But it's also very powerful, where
you can add features through their extensions,
which we'll see more of here in a little bit,
to be able to support different workflows,
different languages, different frameworks,
that sort of thing. So if you scroll down, you see
some of their core features here. IntelliSense,
we'll look at debugging, we'll take a quick look
at some of the built in get features, being able
to work with source control locally with git,
and then work with GitHub and other things like
Bitbucket and things like that. And then the
extension ecosystem, the things that you can
add to VS code to just make it more powerful, is
really the beauty of this thing. So you've got
some testimonials in here, you can scroll down
and kind of read some more of this. But I think
the main thing we want to see here is just
this actually being hands on. Now the one
thing I do want to show you is that there's two
different versions of VS code, there's kind of the
stable edition. That's what you see here, the
stable build. And then there's also the insiders
edition. Now the insider's edition is a version
of VS code that really shows you the latest code
that's coming out from the VS code developers
on a daily basis. And what this means is you'll
get some extra features some new features,
but they may not work all the time, because
these are things that they're testing out before
they officially ship it to the stable version.
So this is for early adopters. This is for
people who really want to try the latest and
greatest features. They don't mind if they get an
occasional broken build here. So things might go
wrong. But I can tell you from my experience,
I have used the VS code insiders edition
for months at a time and never had any issue. So
you can kind of take that for what it's worth.
But you'll get these frequent builds at least
every day with new features and bug fixes.
And the cool thing is you can install VS code,
stable edition as well as the insiders edition,
both on your laptop and or your computer and
not have any issues. So you can try out some
of those latest and greatest features and then
also go back to the stable version if you want to.
So to get started with VS code, you'll download
this you'll run through some of the setup stuff.
And then when you open it, you'll see kind of a
welcome screen. So let me go ahead and open up
VS code on mine. And you'll see how quickly
this loads especially in comparison, this is
actually going to seemingly take longer than
it did because it pulled up on another screen.
But one of the things that I really like is when
you open VS code, it's going to show you often
some updates Of what became new that month. So the
stable edition comes out with new features. And
these are pretty powerful features every single
month. And they give you this kind of newsletter
to show you what all is new. And you can see in
here it has like even images and animated videos.
So VS code just does a really great job of one
adding features and taking feedback on which
features to add, but then also communicating and
let you know, as they do this on a monthly basis,
what things have changed. So if you open this
up for the first time, you can close that out,
you also have kind of a welcome message or welcome
page. This will show you your recent projects that
you've worked on before some help, you can get the
access to the keyboard cheat sheet, we'll talk a
lot about keyboard shortcuts in here. There's tips
and tricks and different things that you can work
on there some features or some sections in here
on how to customize to set up support for other
languages than just JavaScript. So Python and
Java, PHP, working with Azure as a cloud platform,
and Docker as a container system. Those things
don't mean anything to you. That's okay, because
you don't need to worry about it. Those are extra
things that you can customize and use in VS code,
but you absolutely don't have to. So probably the
first thing that you would do in VS code is go
ahead and open a folder. Now I'm opening a project
called dev setups, which is one that I've been
working on recently, which allows users to upload
an image of their desk setup, and you can kind of
scroll through and see different people set up.
So it's just kind of a fun project that I've been
working on. And I've got this thing open in here.
And we'll kind of use this as a way to just kind
of poke around and show you more about the editor.
Now the first thing you'll see this is I'm going
to close this welcome tab here is you've got this
sidebar over here with several different icons,
and the top one is probably what you're looking
for, to get started. And this just shows you all
of the files that you have inside of this open
project. So I've got this dev setups folder,
this project open. And you can see here are all
of the files that are inside of this project.
Now if you're, if you're new to react, if you're
new to JavaScript, don't worry about what these
files do specifically, just know that this is
where you would go and see all of those files.
So in addition to the File Explorer, you also have
a search icon. So you can go and search through
your project. If I wanted to search for react, for
example, this is a really powerful feature in here
will also show me everywhere that react is
inside of this project, you can see it's a lot.
And then I can go in and actually do a replace,
for example, replacing this with something else,
that doesn't really matter. And the cool thing
is VS code will show you kind of in line,
what that replace will do. So react will become
something else, this is not something I want to
do. So I'm gonna go ahead and back out of that.
So we'll talk a little bit more about search and
replace in a minute. But you come down, you also
have a source control tab. So as you make changes,
and we'll cover some of the basics of this, you'll
see the files that are changed, you'll see the
files that are ready to be committed, you'll see
ones that have been staged, and so on, and so on.
So all of your Git stuff you can do right inside
of VS code, which is really nice. There's also
a debugging section down here. So this allows
you to do like a true debugging experience,
where you can have breakpoints and inspect
variables and all that sort of stuff.
And then lastly, you'll come down and see there's
the extensions tab. And this is where you can
search for extensions to add different pieces
of functionality to your VS code instance. Now
the couple of couple of tabs I have down here,
these are extra ones that I have installed from
extensions. So we don't need to cover that. But
when you start off, you'll see these form right
here. And you'll also notice that your VS code,
probably color wise looks a little bit different,
a little bit different. So we'll cover themes
here in a minute. And I use the cobalt to theme.
So if you want to go ahead and look at this
yourself, you can go to the extensions tab,
you can search cobalt two, and then when you
get to an extension, you can click to install
it and it'll be ready to go. And yours
will start to look a lot more like mine.
But I will cover some of the different things
that I have customized in mind here in a second.
So one of the things that I think is really
neat with VS code is you can kind of customize
the way things look and your space that you're
working with. With using shortcuts. This is one
of my favorite things. So let me open up. Here's
an app CSS file. So here's a random CSS file.
And I can do command B on Mac or Ctrl B on
Windows. And for all the shortcuts that I
mentioned going forward command will be on
Mac and Ctrl V the equivalent on Windows.
So I will probably just stick with command,
or I'll say command and control. And you'll
know command is for Mac and Ctrl is for
Windows. So with that said, command control B
allows me to toggle open this sidebar. And
this is really nice because as a developer,
I might want to look at my files here. But then
as I start to write code, I might want that to
go away so I have more room to actually write the
code that I care about. So I use Command B command
Ctrl V to toggle this open all the time. And then
you can take that one step further. If you hover
over these icons, you can do Command Shift II
to go directly to the Explorer, or you can do
Command Shift F to go directly to find her, or
the search and replace, you can do Command Shift
G, actually, this one specifically is Ctrl, Shift
G, so Ctrl, Shift g on both Windows and Mac for
the source control, and then Command Shift D to
go straight to debugging. And then lastly, again,
command B to make that toggle the sidebar menu
open and close completely, which is pretty nice.
Now, you also will get some information
down here on this bottom bar, I've got
a few extensions installed, so I get a little bit
more information than what you will probably see,
but you'll have a little bit of information about
probably the branch that you're working on. So in
this case, I'm working in a master branch inside
of this repository. And it shows me down there,
which one I am working on. So you get a little bit
of information down there. And you'll get a little
bit of information up here to show you which file
you're working on. Now I want to show you a couple
of cool things with working with files. There's
a grid tab system in VS code where I can open
a file, you can have two files open at one time.
And then also I can drag these over to the side.
And notice you get this kind of darkened effect
that splits the screen. Well, I can have two
files side by side. And I can resize these to any
combination of sizing that I want. So not only
can you have to file side by side, you can also
bring out files in a grid system with rows and
columns. So now I've got two went to pain side by
side. And then on the right side, I've split that
top and bottom. And not only can you do that, you
can also customize how those are laid out as well.
So you can get as crazy about this as you want
to with just adding on more and more files.
And I don't know that there's really a limit here.
But at a certain point, it's not really practical
to have all these files. But here's three going
vertically on this column and then two over here.
So you can do this, any combination of that you
want. I typically stick with just having to file
side by side, I don't usually use multiple rows,
I typically just use two different columns. And
I didn't show this. But you can also take a
window over here and have three side by side
and however many you want. So there's only so
practical depending on the size of your screen,
but you have the flexibility to kind of make
that your own, which is really nice. Alright,
one thing I want to let you know is your kind
of Holy Grail, your master command inside of VS
code is going to be the command palette. So this
is Command Shift p or Ctrl, Shift P. And after
you do that you have the ability to kind of search
for whatever you want any command that you can run
inside of VS code you can do from here. So one of
the things I want to show you is something called
Zen mode under view. So view toggles in mode, and
was in mode will do is basically get rid of all
the fluff. So all of the border items up here, all
the sidebar, all of that stuff is completely gone.
And now I can just focus on my code. Lots of
people love this feature where they've got
no distractions, they just see code. I don't
personally use this because I don't get too
distracted by the other stuff going on. But
I think this is a pretty cool feature inside
of VS code to be able to use, I'm going
to toggle this back off by running that
command again from the command palette. Again,
command palette is going to be your Savior,
you can always go to the command palette and
search for anything that you're looking for.
Now another thing that you will see is on yours by
default, you will probably see this mini map thing
over here. And this is extremely useful. If we get
into what's a bigger file. In here, do we have a
big file. So if we have a much bigger file like
this, the mini map over here will allow you to
kind of scroll through all of these lines of code
pretty quickly. So instead of having to scroll
with my mouse wheel over here, you can just kind
of select and really jump to wherever you want
inside of your code pretty quickly. So I don't
leave the mini map on just because I don't want
to take up space in my instance of VS code. But
you can leave mini map there and use it to jump
around really big files. Now again, going to the
command palette, you have the ability to toggle on
the mini map and add it or get rid of it. So you
can do that just like that. Alright, I mentioned
search and replace. So we started by doing this
over in the left over here. But we can also do
this right inside of a file. So if I wanted to
search for center, I could do Command F and this
will open the find window and I can type in center
for example, I can also and you may have noticed
that did this before. If I get rid of this and I
select a piece of text and then do Command F it
will go ahead and automatically populate that with
that piece of text, which is really neat. You can
also from here go down and say all right, instead
of center I want to be right and I don't think
this is a valid property for justify content, but
that's not really the point. So inside of here,
I can do a replace of one instance or replace of
all. So if you remember the shortcuts for this,
you can actually do some search and replace stuff
really really powerfully and really quickly.
Easily inside of VS code. Alright, so I can run
this and do replace you see that replaces right
there. Now this is, obviously in just one file,
you can also do the same sort of thing inside
of what we showed earlier, where I can search for
center, for example. And everywhere I have center,
not something I probably want to do, I can replace
this with right, you can see all the instances of
where that is. And you can even by file by file,
say alright, and this specific file until when
just replace all of the instances of center with
right and just that file. So you can go by file
by file, or line by line, you can click on these
and go to it and make a decision on whether or not
this is something you actually want to change. And
VS code does a really cool example of showing you,
you're going to change this line to this line
by replacing center with right. So the search
and replace stuff in VS code is really, really
powerful. You can save yourself a lot of time
if you understand some of the shortcuts
of how to trigger the search and replace,
and then go ahead and act on them. So speaking
of shortcuts, we've mentioned a few already,
we mentioned Command or Ctrl B to toggle open
this window. There's also a few neat ones where
you can do command W to close a file, I use this
a lot. And then also if you have two files open
or multiple files, open whatever these are, you
can Ctrl tab to switch through these files. So
you can toggle through them like this, I use
this a lot as well. You can also do Ctrl Shift
Tab to toggle back the opposite way. So if I've
got a bunch of different files open up here, and
I want to go from profile to home, that's good.
But if I want to go from profile to tailwind CSS,
I can do it backwards by doing Ctrl Shift and
tab to go and see that pop up as well. So Ctrl,
tab and Ctrl Shift Tab on Mac, and Windows
will allow you to toggle through those files.
Now another thing that I do a lot is I do command
P to open or to search files to open them. So
if I want to search for my app j s, I will do
command p, I'll type the name of that file and
then enter and it will open that thing for me.
Now, I usually leave this sidebar close so that
I have more space for code. And then I just come
in and do this where I can search for the file,
press Enter. And now I've got that file open right
here. And then I can command w or Ctrl W to close
a file. And then I can toggle through that using
these Ctrl tab and Ctrl Shift Tab shortcuts to
go forwards and backwards. I think one of the
main things, main pieces of advice that I have
for people that are writing code is learn to use
your shortcuts, it will save you a lot of time
writing code, the less amount of time you spend on
a mouse, the more time you spend on your keyboard,
the better off you're you'll be and the more
productive you will be. Alright, so a couple of
other things I want to share with you is just how
to work is just how to navigate through your text.
So what I mean is if I want to go from right here
to right here, I don't want to have to click so
I could just arrow over so I could type the arrow
key a bunch of times that's not really productive.
Or I can start to use some shortcuts to help me
navigate this text. So if you hold down Option
and press left or right, what this will do is
it will navigate word by word. And that word
is kind of a loose definition where like this
thing is a word, this thing is a word. This is
kind of a series of connected characters. So it
really just kind of goes by where the space is.
So you can navigate word by word This way, you can
also hold down on Mac, you can hold down Command
and go left or right to get to the beginning and
end of a line. So this is really helpful as well.
Now you can also hold down Command and go top
or bottom or up and down to get to the top or
bottom of the file. And on a Windows machine, I
think you can do Ctrl and then home and end to do
the same sort of thing. So home an end will take
you to the beginning and end of a line. If you
hold down your control and do that you can get to
the top or bottom of a file as well. So you might
have to play around with that and to get kind
of comfortable in doing that. But it is really,
really helpful. If you can start to learn to use
your shortcuts to navigate through texts quickly,
you can save yourself some time, keep your hands
on the keyboard, keep them off of the mouse and
really become a much more productive programmer.
So I want to make sure that I undo all of these
changes. And I can do that with Command or
Control Z. So I can hold that down and undo
all the changes that I just made. You can also as
you would probably expect, if you've used other
editors, you can select a line and do Command C
or Ctrl C and then Command or Ctrl V to paste,
you can do that. But even cooler, you don't have
to select the line. So if I'm on this line, and
I want to copy this entire thing, I can just do
Command C and then Command V so I don't even have
to select it, it will basically inherently select
the entire line by itself. Now another one of my
favorites is you can use Command D or control
D to select the actual word that you're on.
So if I wanted my character was inside of this
word, I could use Command D And then I can use
Command F to be able to search that thing. And
then I could go and replace it with something
else if I wanted to as well. So again, learning
these shortcuts, learning how to work with them
will really save you some time. Now another thing
that will save you some time in VS code is the
built in IntelliSense. That VS code provides you.
So what I mean is, if I start typing in document,
you see I get a bunch of things pop open here. But
if I'm working with the document element, object
inside of JavaScript, and I press dot, now VS code
knows that this thing is the document object. And
I can scroll through to see all the different
things I can do with this document object.
So if I scroll down, you can see the difference in
these little icons here, this little purple one,
those are actually functions. So a common
thing you'll do in JavaScript is add an event
listener. So I could press Enter on this. And
if I open up the parentheses to go ahead and
call this function, you can see VS code is also
giving me some IntelliSense, on what parameters
are required here. So the first parameter is
going to be a type. So you can see things like
there's 86 more, there's a ton in here. So these
are the different events that you can listen for.
And it's saying that that thing is a type of
event. And then the The second thing you pass
is an actual callback function. So if I type in
click, notice it's giving me IntelliSense in here,
so not only can I get click, I can get close and
can play and cancel and those sorts of things. And
then, if I go down to the second parameter, I can
read through this documentation is show me what
all is needed, including the callback, which is
the second part. So IntelliSense is something that
I use all of the time. Because as a developer,
I don't necessarily want to write every single
word or every single character, every single line
of code, I would rather have a tool take care of
assisting that for me. And VS code does a really,
really great job of providing you really powerful
IntelliSense that you can use to save yourself a
lot of time. Now another really cool feature, I'm
going to get rid of all of these changes. Another
feature that I like a lot is I'm going to add a
new file in here, we haven't really shown how to
do new files. But if I click the New File up here,
I can get a new test HTML. And I love this
feature right here. It's a feature called Emmet,
which is built into VS code, but Emmet is its own
thing. So if you look up Emmet snippets in here,
you can go to Doc's dot IO. And you can
learn a lot more about this. But basically,
it's powerful shortcuts that you can use for your
HTML and CSS. So if I do the bang character here,
it shows me VS code does with IntelliSense, that
there's an Emmet abbreviation for this. And this
will give me the boilerplate code to an HTML file.
That's really powerful. I couldn't write all of
this stuff from scratch myself personally. So I
use this little bang character snippet to generate
the boilerplate stuff or code for an HTML file.
Now, you can take this several many steps further,
if I type in an h1, for example, and press enter
that comes from Emmet. So I could do that this
is an h1. I can also if I wanted a div with a
class of container, I could do div dot container.
And this will add a class to a div with that class
of container. That's pretty cool. I could also do
div with an ID of contam. Not very creative. So
I could do container here as well. So there's a
div with an ID of container. I could also
do a div with a class of container and an
ID of something special. What again, not super
creative here. There's an ID and a container.
And what's even cooler is if I undo this and go
back and get rid of div and then finish typing
this out, div is kind of implied here. So if
I don't specify the element that I'm creating,
it will infer it as a div. So I can also do an
h1 with a class of title, and then the ID of
cool title or something like that. So it does all
of that stuff in line. You can also repeat stuff.
So if I did a ul, inside of that ul, I could do
an Li times three. And that will generate three
allies for me, you can do an input with a type
of text. There's all sorts of these snippets to
make writing your HTML so much quicker and easier.
It's really worth looking and spending some time
to figure out how to leverage the power of Emmet
to help you generate snippets or use snippets to
generate your HTML code. Now, you can also do this
in your CSS, I'm going to get rid of this file.
So I'm going to get rid of this thing. And then
I'll open up a CSS file so so I'm going to try to
create a new test CSS file in here. And if I start
off with targeting every element for example,
if I wanted to set the cursor pointer, notice I
type cu R and I get some IntelliSense with Emmet
abbreviations for cursor pointer. I could
do a padding so if I type in p that will
give me a lot of things in Well, this is just kind
of regular IntelliSense. But if I finish typing
p 10. For example, notice that autocompletes
to padding of 10, or if I do m 10, things like
that. So Emmet is really, really powerful for you
to be able to create HTML, CSS code using these
really short code, these really nice shortcodes
or snippets, and save yourself a lot of time and
energy as well. So you definitely want to spend
a little bit of time just kind of figuring out
how to use Emmet, to work best for you. Now let's
talk about some VS code setting. So if you really
kind of interested in what I have set up here
and how I have this set up, let's go and look at
my settings. And so you can open the settings by
going to this cog wheel over here, or you can do
command, comma or control comments to open up
your settings panel. So let's start with just
the font family. So I have in here installed on
my machine something called Cascadia code. Let me
pull that up for you Cascadia code. This is a free
font by Microsoft that is really, really nice.
So you can install this cast this Cascadia code
font, and then you can choose to use it inside
of your font family here. Now just to show you
if I were to get rid of this. So if I cut that,
and now come back to my code, this looks very
different. So this is kind of the default stuff
that's set up in VS code. But I like to have that
really fancy Cascadia code here and now it looks
better. So notice also that as I save or update
the settings VS code is reloading in real time
to show you those new changes, which is really,
really nice. Another thing I love with my font
is I have something called a font ligatures turned
on. And this is an example of a setting that you
have to change directly inside of the settings
that JSON file so not just inside of your VS
code editor. And you see I've got lots that are
changed in here. But I can set the font ligatures
to true. And font ligatures are these cool little
combination of characters that I really enjoy.
So let me show you a couple of examples of this.
You can type double equals Now see, that becomes
one character there. Instead of two, if I do a
triple character now becomes a three barred thing.
If I do a not equals, now this will come together
like that. And if I do a not equal equals, so you
can see that comes together too. You also get a
little arrow icon. So if you do arrow functions in
JavaScript, you can get that as well. So this is
a personal preference. I think font ligatures are
really cool. But if you don't like the way those
look, you can turn those off by coming into your
settings JSON, and then just turning that thing
to false. I think they come false by default,
so you may not even have to worry about it.
So another thing you can look at is your
font size. I love how easy it is in VS code
to just search for your property, see what the
different things are that you can change and then
change that right here. So I've got my font size
set to 20. If I bump this up, for example, to 40,
now my code is going to look a lot bigger, which
is probably not very practical. But this is really
easy to just change if you're doing a demo or
something. And you want to be able to show people
your code, you can also change your zoom level. So
if I type in a four, for example, notice this is
going to zoom in VS code as a whole. So this is
going to make everything bigger. Again, if you're
doing a demo, for example, and you want people to
be able to see every part of VS code a lot bigger,
you can do that with your zoom level, I'm going to
turn this back down to two to make sure that I
can see this comfortably. Now you can also do a
command or control and plus or minus to zoom open
as well. And you see that when I do that you see
the change in here. So you can do that with your
shortcuts or through the settings just like that.
Alright, there are tons of different settings in
here that you could change one of the ones that
I like is a word wrap. So what that means is if I
have a line of code that goes really really far,
and I'm just typing out kind of dummy code here.
Notice after I crossed this bar, it wraps over
to the next line. So I personally like to have
this turned on so that I don't have to scroll
horizontally to see the end of a line of code. And
you can notice if I turn off on here, now I have
to scroll to be able to see this, I personally
don't like that. So I usually leave word wrap on.
Now you can also set the word wrap column.
So notice this bar over here is set to 80.
If I set this bar to four, for example, this is
going to look terrible. Now, if I set this to the
word wrap column, now this thing is going to wrap
my stuff at four characters, which is probably not
what you want, even if I set this to 40. That's
still going to look a little tough there to see.
So I'm going to reset this back to 80. And then
I'm going to turn this back to kind of regular
and now again, you can see this is wrapping
at this line and it has that line to show you
what is there. Alright, there's some other cool
settings down here. If you do anything with your
files over here, you can tell VS code to not show
you certain files so you can add a pattern in here
and I can add node modules for example, and this
directory should just disappear after I do that.
So notice node module is not no longer showing
inside of that. And then I can just undo that by
getting rid of this setting here by clicking this
X on node modules. Now that thing has come back,
and you get a really, really kind of powerful
ability to customize this thing here. Alright,
you can scroll through and do tons of different
settings in here, I'll show you a few more as
we go through one of the ones that I like is the
cursor to be blinking. And you can have this to be
an expand as well. So this is just kind of a
cool effect, where you see my cursor will kind
of expand there, I think that's kind of nice. And
then you can also set your cursor style to a line
or a block, for example, now this thing is a lot
thicker on that letter, that's actually kind of
wild, I've never done that one before. So you can
customize so many things in VS code, it's really,
really nice, I would, I would recommend just
spending some time inside of these settings
to really try to get things the way that you
think, work best for you. Alright, that said,
let's move into extensions and themes. And let's
start with themes because these are going to be
extensions themselves, and they can kind of show
you how to customize the look and feel of your
editor even more. So I mentioned that I use the
cobalt to theme so you can search this and search
cobalt to and then this is the official theme by
West boss. And so after you install that theme,
then you can select it and use it so you can
you get a button in here for set color theme.
You can also go to your magical command palette
with Command Shift v. And if you search theme,
now you can scroll down to the color theme.
Press Enter and now you can choose and watch
this as I scroll through VS code will update in
real time to show you what these different themes
will look like. And you can see there's a ton of
really cool, different ways that you can do this.
Night Owl is one of my favorites. This is from
Sarah dresner. I like nite owl a lot. And this
has a couple of different versions. So you have
night owl with no metallics there you got this red
thing I can't imagine really working with that.
But it's a cool one. shades of purple is a really
nice one as well from a mod a wise hopefully
I'm pronouncing that right. So he created this
thing because he's a big fan of purple. And
I actually think it looks really really cool.
There solarize dark and these are another one I
want to show you is winter is coming by john Papa,
I really like this one a lot as well. I think this
is a really really nice kind of dark theme here.
So you can search for tons of different themes.
You can search for the ones I just mentioned night
owl here, you get that one there. And then Winter
is coming. So there's the Winter is coming one.
So if you just search themes in here, now you
can come and see a ton of different things that
you can try out. There's a Linux set of Linux
themes in here. There's duo tone, dark themes,
there's zeplin themes that's kind of wild and
cool. There's tons of things in here, they're
really easy to install, you just click a button
to install. And then you go into your settings and
you choose which theme you want to be active. So I
let you kind of play around, I showed you a couple
of my favorites, you can go in here and look
for a bunch of different ones and go from there.
Now let's talk about some other awesome extensions
that you're absolutely going to want to have.
Here's a few that I really like there's an
extension called prettier, which does code
formatting and VS code. So you can install this
extension, and then also come in to your settings
and say format on save. So this is a combination
of using an extension as well as a setting for
this. And if you set this to true, what's going
to happen or if you check this, what's going to
happen is it's going to use prettier. And it's
going to format my code every time I save. So if I
kind of mess up some of the tabs in here and I
put this stuff like all over the place. And it
This just looks like really terrible code. When
I save this now it's going to format all of that
stuff for me. So the combination of using prettier
as an extension, as well as the setting in VS code
for format on Save is incredibly powerful. I do
this for all of my projects. So this is definitely
one that's worth having. I also use an extension
called Advanced new file. And what this allows me
to do if I come and grab the right one, so this is
the one with dashes. What this allows me to do is
instead of coming over here and choosing to click
to add a new file, I can run my new file command.
So advanced new file. If I run that, it gives me a
drop down to choose which directory I want to put
this file in. So I could put this in the workspace
root. And then I can call this test dot j s. And
then now that file is created. And you can see
that over here, again, I look for any excuse to
use shortcuts and extensions to help me do stuff
versus coming over and actually clicking on things
with a mouse. So that's one of the ones that
I use a lot myself as well. Another one I find
handy is the better comments, extension. What
this will do is allow me in my code to write
different types of comments like to do and it
will highlight that different color. So if I say
something like exclamation, that's going to
turn this thing red. And there's also a star
for a green comment. And then if you define
something as a puram, it will highlight that
or color that as well. So I think this is really
useful for you to be able to leave code comments
and have them be kind of highlighted so that you
can really see as you scroll through your code,
they really jump out at you. And you can see what
is really useful there. So another great feature,
especially if you're a JavaScript developer,
is there's an extension called Cuoco,
which gives you a JavaScript playground and
TypeScript. So if I run the quokka command,
I can do a new JavaScript file. And then inside
of here, I've got like a live JavaScript play pad
or scratch pad or whatever you want to call it.
And I can type JavaScript right inside of here.
And I can see the output over here as well as the
output logged out over on the side as well. Now
this is anytime I want to try out a new piece of
JavaScript, this is my go to this is what I use.
The alternative would be to go into Google
Chrome, for example, or whatever browser you
use and open up the console and type something
in here. But that's not really convenient when
you're already inside of your VS code editor.
And you already know shortcuts and things and
snippets and stuff that you can use inside of VS
code. So this is what I do. quokka is amazing for
just a live scratchpad for either JavaScript or
TypeScript. Another one that is great is the live
server extension. And if I searched for this,
this is ritwik day. And this has over 7 million
downloads, it's really incredible. So if I typed
in like a test dot html here, and stub this out,
using my Emmet snippets, and came down and
said, Hello, world, we're inside of this file,
I can do my command palette, and I can do live
server. And you can open this with live server.
And what this will do is it will serve this on a
real port. So we'll start up a server, serve this
from a real port. And I can update this file. And
as soon as I save, now, it's reflected inside of
the browser as well. Because of that live server
extension, it handles all of that stuff for me,
which is really, really amazing, you'll definitely
want to have this if you're doing any sort of
basic HTML, CSS and JavaScript stuff, installing
that extension will make it really easy to run
that stuff. A couple of other nice ones, there's
a polo code extension, this one allows you to take
really sweet looking images of your code. So you
basically copy in some of your code, you can see
the example GIF here, you copy some of your code
you paste it in, and then Polo code will generate
this really sweet looking snippet in here for you.
So that you can have pictures that you can share
on Twitter, or in your blog post or things like
that. There's also the auto rename tags. So if you
do any HTML work, again, this one is really nice.
And what this does, is if I start to update the
title here and make this an h1, notice it's
auto updating the closing tag as well. So
you'll definitely want to have that extension to
help you out with some some of your HTML stuff.
And there's also the bracket, pair colorizer.
And this one is pretty sweet. Because inside of
JavaScript, this will color your brackets to match
each other to show you which one goes with each.
So notice that we've got a purple color
here. And then we've got a blue color
to show that this one goes with this one, this one
with this one, and this one with this one. This is
really nice. It's kind of subtle, but especially
when you're reading code and having to do that,
it's nice to just have it be pretty easy to look
at and see really quickly. Alright, so let me
just scroll through some of the other extensions
that I use that I think would be useful for you
as well. There's one here called bookmarks. This
allows you to set bookmarks in your code. So if
you're working in really, really big files, or
really big project, you can set bookmarks inside
of your files and then be able to toggle through
your bookmarks. If you have like really important
spots inside of different pieces of code, you can
mark those and then be able to move through them
using the commands with this bookmarks, extension.
There's also cloak This is a real really nice one.
If you're working with private credentials,
and you do screen recordings, like I do,
cloak will take a dot CSV file. So if you use
dot E and V to have your environment variables,
and they're private, and you don't want people
to see those, which you probably don't, you can
turn on cloak and it will hide those things from
everybody that's watching this is really useful.
As it says here, if you're presenting onstage
if you're streaming on Twitch or YouTube,
if you record a screencast
of your code like we do here.
Another nice one is CSS peak. This
allows you to to view the CSS for a given
class or ID. So you can pick that where you don't
have to go all the way over to the CSS file,
or if it's coming from bootstrap or something like
that. You don't have to open up the source files.
You can kind of see that right in line in your
code. Next up, we've got the debugger for Chrome.
This one, we will actually have a section on
this coming up of debugging inside of Visual
Studio code and we'll use this extension to
do that. There's this dot E and v one. This
is pretty simple, but it's just gives you kind of
a color syntax here for working with environment
variables inside of a dot E and V file. So if
you've never done environment variables, if you've
never done dot E and V files, that's totally
fine. If you do this one might be useful for you.
Next up is the editor config. This is a basic
sort of formatting thing for your code that
you can use across different types of editor.
So if you have this dot editor config file,
you can use this and embed it in your project and
kind of make sure that your projects stay with a
certain format across different teams and people
editing and that sort of thing. So this extension
enables that ability inside of VS code. If you are
a react developer, this is the most popular react
extension that I know of with snippets.
We'll talk about snippets more in a second
for react Redux graph, qL, and React Native. So
there's lots of good stuff in there that you can
take advantage of. Alright, this is not maybe
relevant to everyone. But I just wanted to kind
of highlight this extension here is for fauna
dB, a great database option that you can use
for your applications. And I just am wanting
to highlight here that there are extensions for
lots of third party technologies as well. So
whether you use fauna dB, or Firebase, or netlify,
or a ton of different options out there, you
can almost always find an extension. So if you
have a product, a third party product outside of
Microsoft outside of VS code that you work with,
go and give it a shot to see if there's
something out there that you can find.
Import costs is another one that is great for
JavaScript developers, this will basically
just show you how big your import statements
are. So if you look at the example image that
is not showing here, but if they had the example
image up, it would show you that you'll get some
text right next to the import statement to show
you how big that import is. That way, you can
make sure that you're only importing the things
that you really need, and not anything extra.
Alright, we've got the live share extension
down here, this one will actually have
a section on in a minute, we've also got the
markdown PDF, this is something I'm looking to
try out myself to create an E book where you
can type markdown inside of VS code and then
be able to export that to a PDF. Now speaking of
markdown, just to kind of show you how this works.
In VS code, you get some pretty good
support for markdown right inside of
here. So if I open a markdown file, here is
the source. But then I can also if I open
up the command palette, I can open up a preview
to the side. So here's my markdown preview right
in line with all the markdown stuff that I see
over here. So I see source code, as well as a
preview all inside of the editor. Now I've used
a few different things for editing markdown,
I've used stack edit, which is in the browser.
But this is really nice, because it's in the
same place where I write my code. And I can
see that live preview right there as well.
So with that extension that I mentioned, you can
take that markdown and then export it to a PDF for
an E book or something like that.
Alright, and I think we've covered
the majority of the most important ones here.
So again, just know, the extension ecosystem
in VS code is great, there's tons of stuff
there, there's lots of different options,
if you have an idea for something, go ahead
and search for it, it's probably already there.
Alright, now that we've covered extensions,
let's talk about how to customize your keyboard
shortcuts. And I waited until we covered
extensions, because some of these things
you can just kind of get with an extension
and take care of all of that stuff for you.
So if you hit the settings, cog
wheel over here in the bottom left,
you can open up your keyboard shortcuts. And as
always, if you open up your command palette, you
could also do this from here. So this preferences,
open keyboard shortcuts will get you to the same
place. And keyboard shortcuts in VS code are
really nice. I think this is a pretty powerful
thing for you to be able to customize. So as
you would probably expect they have a list of
commands that you can then add a key binding for
so add cursor above, and then they show you the
the shortcut here let's do let's search for
search, or actually, let's do a find. So what
is the shortcut for fine, we talked about
this earlier, it's Command F or Ctrl, F.
And then you can see there's also
lots of different other options with
find as well where you can find previous
and next and so on. So this thing shows
that this command is going to be Command F and
you can actually edit this right in line, which
I think is pretty nice. So pretty nice. So if
we now specify some weird combination of things,
so I'm doing command Alt Shift, I, that's probably
not what I want, but then I press enter and now
this thing has been updated. And now I would need
to press Command Shift I to go ahead and find
something. So let me go ahead and fix this back
to Command F that's what we really want. Alright,
so that goes back to normal. And let's just search
for another option in here. Let's see if we.
If we type select and then add selection
to next find match. So if you remember,
we actually use this command Command D earlier to
select a given words if you're inside of a word,
you can use Command D to select it and go from
there. You can also see in here we've got,
we've got shortcuts for this is actually the
bookmarks extension. So that bookmarks extension
that we talked about a few seconds ago has its own
keyboard shortcuts or commands that you can add
keyboard shortcuts as well. So some extensions
that you install will have commands available,
some of them will already have key
binding set to those, some of them
won't have key binding set. So you have to go
into the command palette to check those out.
Alright, one of the ones that I have customized
myself, and I kind of alluded to this early on,
is the advanced new file. So when I want to
create a new file, if I come back to let me
close out some of these extensions, when
I come into a file, and I press Command n,
this is going to ask me where I want to create the
file and I can say root. And then I can say test
dot something. And that's going to create
that file and open it inside of VS code,
which is a really nice workflow. Now, let me
show you what happens if I don't have that set.
So if I, if I just remove this key binding
by right click, and then remove key binding,
that will go away. And then if I press Command n
inside of here, it doesn't do exactly what I want,
where it creates this new file, but it doesn't
have a name, and it doesn't, it's not in a
directory anywhere. So I would then need to go
and save that file directly. So that's why I
like having that advanced new file extension,
and then specifically set to that key binding.
Now I can just update the one that is here.
So this advanced new file, I can just do this.
And now say command in and that thing should be
okay. And notice also that when I did that, it's
telling me that three commands already have this
binding. So this will allow me to know that there
are some commands already have this and I need to
double check, hey, do I really want to do this.
And then VS code is smart enough to know that this
command down here the new untitled file, that's
the one that I show you showed you that for me
is not really optimal. So this is default source.
And then mine, the one that I created up here is a
user source. So it's going to take precedence over
the one that comes default with VS code. So it
handles the overriding these commands really well.
Alright, so there's my new file. And then if
I trigger this now with command n, and notice
that there's no delay here, this automatically
reloads as soon as I update the command shortcuts,
now they're available for me to use. Another thing
that I want to show you is if we come down here,
and we'll talk about the built in terminal here
in a minute, but if we look at this last one,
not only does it have a command and a key binding,
it also has a win. Now this is basically a win is
basically a state that you can use inside
of VS code to determine when this shortcut
should take place, which makes the combination of
shortcuts very powerful. So let's look up VS code
shortcuts. And I want to show you just so
you can be able to go out and look at these
later on for yourself, if you need to do
some extra research on how to do this. So
let's search for the win. And I'm scrolling down
here to the when clause context. So you can do
some conditional things in here when the editor
language ID equals TypeScript. So if you're
specifically in a TypeScript file, a command
might do something specific versus another one,
if you're on Linux, or if you're on Windows, you
can detect that way, and so on, and so on. So then
you come down, and you can see all the different
contexts, the things that you can use to determine
when your your shortcut should be triggered, based
on that key binding. So if the editor is focused,
if you're actually focused on the editor, if
the editor has selection, many, you've already
selected a piece of text. If you scroll down,
you see the operating systems is Windows, Mac,
Linux, there's also an is web because there's
a lot of embedded versions of VS code inside
of the browser, which is pretty cool. And then
you've got some different modes. Here, we'll talk
about debugging here in a second, there's so many
different options in here for you to choose from.
This gives you kind of the ultimate ability to
customize when your shortcut should be triggered.
Now notice that I've got these three key bindings
here. And again, VS code is smart enough to know
when to trigger each one. So because I have this
advanced new file is a user source, it takes
precedent over the default source here. And then
this command in one, the terminal is focused. So
when I'm actually down here in this terminal will
take precedence over that if I'm actually focused
on the terminal, so VS code already has this
ability to kind of take your commands that you
define and then add precedents on top of them.
So now that you know how to customize all those
shortcuts, and again, there's tons in here you can
scroll through, you can search for what you want,
and just customize it to your heart's content.
After you have that, or maybe even before you
have that, it's interesting to know that there
are some key map extensions in the marketplace as
well. So if for instance, you come from sublime,
so you use Sublime Text for several years,
you come over to VS code, and the shortcuts
aren't exactly what you're looking for.
Well, the Sublime Text keymap and settings
importer that can actually import settings from
sublime and then all Also basically override all
of your shortcuts to match what should have been,
or what would have been inside of sublime.
That way you can keep the same shortcuts that
you're used to. And you can kind of go about
your business just like you had in the past.
Now there's sublime, I wonder if there's notepad
plus plus notepad plus plus key map, there's that
one, I wonder if there is Adam, key map all
the different Yep, there's Adam key map there.
And then there's probably brackets as a key map,
maybe there's not brackets as a key map. But
you can find for most of those popular
editors, text editors, you can find a key map
extension that you can just bring right in, and
then go about your business just like you had in
the past. So that is the section on customizing
shortcuts. The other thing I want to talk about
customizing is your snippets. So if we look
inside of just a JavaScript file down here,
I'm going to show you a couple of snippets that
are kind of built into VS code. So if I type CLG,
notice VS code is now popping up with this snippet
here, and it shows me what it's going to output.
So it's going to output a console dot log. So
there's a snippet there. And we talked about all
the IntelliSense that VS code gives you. So if
we do document dot, and then get element by ID,
something like that, we can go ahead and complete.
So VS code gives you some built in snippets,
and then some IntelliSense on knowing
what functions and things are available.
But if you want to customize and add your own
snippets, you can also do that. So the way
that snippets work is snippets get stored
inside of a JSON file. And if we click on
the cog wheel and go to user snippets, or if we
just open the command palette and open snippets
as well configure user snippets, it's going to
ask you which type of language are you working
with. So you can have global snippets which apply
just anywhere, regardless of what file you're in.
And or you can have snippets that are specific
to certain languages. So if we look down
at the JavaScript, JSON, I've actually got a
few of these that I use in my code. And I'll
kind of walk you through how those work. So
let's just start off with the very basic here
of the console log example. So if I wanted to have
a new snippet for doing a console log statement,
I would one give this kind of a title or a key
here, and this could be Jq console log, and then
that thing is going to point to or have a value of
an object that will have different properties. So
the first thing is the prefix. And this is going
to be what is the shortcode that you want to use
to trigger this snippet. Now, this is not super
practical, I'm just using this to differentiate
between the other CLG. But let's do a prefix
here of Jq CLG for console log, and then we'll
do the body. And the body here is going to be a
string. So we'll do the body is console dot log.
And then we'll have the description. So
if we needed some extra details in here,
this will write a console log statement. And so
pretty straightforward. So after you save that
thing, now this snippet is ready for you to use.
So inside of my JavaScript file, it doesn't matter
what JavaScript file I'm in, I can type Jq. And
notice I get the prefix here of popping up the
IntelliSense for my snippet, and it shows me the
description over here, and it shows me what it's
actually going to write. So if I press enter,
now it actually writes out that log statement.
Now a couple of things, we might want to update,
instead of ending with my cursor over here,
I might want to actually end with my cursor in
the middle so that I can type in the input for
that console log. So one of the things you can do
is something called tab stops. So if I do a.or $1,
sign one here, this is saying that I'm going to be
entering in some pieces of information. And this
is the first one that I'm going to enter. So now
if I do the same thing jq C log and press enter,
now you see my inputs, my cursor there, so I
can type in my object is what I want to log,
and then come over, and maybe I want to
actually include a semicolon. And then
after I finished entering in the information
here, I want to go down to the next line,
which can get kind of interesting. So a couple of
things, let's go ahead and add this semi colon.
And then if you're doing snippets that have
multiple lines, you need to put them in an array.
So you have an array of strings. So there's
the first string there, and the second one
is going to be on a new line. So we can have
that be tap stop to for example. So let's try
this out again. And let's trigger the snippet
with J qq CLG. Press Enter, type in my object,
and then tab will take me to the next tab stop.
Now you can have as many tab stops as you want.
The interesting thing about this one is the dollar
sign zero is actually going to be the very last
place that you end. So after you finish all of
your tabs, labs that are one through X or Y or N
or however many you do. dollar sign zero is going
to be the very last snippet. So that's going to be
where your cursor goes. After you finished all the
previous tab stops. So let's save this. Let's do
the same this We'll do the same thing, I just want
to show you the tapsnap of zebra there. So jQi
uclg, and type in my object and then return or
tab, actually. And that will bring me down to this
next line. So that's a pretty simple example. And
these can obviously get a lot more complicated.
Here's an example of will actually another
simple example of using environment variables.
And I do this a lot where if you're using
environment variables, you have to type
out process dot E and V dot something. And
maybe you don't want to have to do that.
So I created the sixth this this extension, the
snippet, that is just n v, and that will replace
it with process dot E and V. And then I can type
in the actual variable that I'm working with.
Alright, and if I scroll up a little bit, let's
scroll up to the top, a couple of the ones that I
like here is a use state hook and react, this may
be completely new to you. So don't worry if this
is new. But same thing here, it's got kind of the
key here, the title, it's got a prefix, it doesn't
have a description, because I didn't add one. But
then it's got the body, and it has two tabs up. So
here is one and tabs. Two are actually three tabs,
tabs, here's tabs out three and then tab sub zero
goes to the end of the line, and then I could
return to get down to the next one. Now, here's a
great example of one that would be really useful.
And they have one built in to VS code. If we type
in four, there's a couple of different for loop
snippets. So here's one that comes from vs. Code,
itself. And then here's the one that I created,
which is for AR, fo AR AR AR. So inside of here,
you can see this is a multi line snippet, because
it's got an array, and each line or each item
in the array is a string. And so we define a
pretty standard for loop that uses an array.
So it says Dollar Index, well, we haven't seen
this yet, we've seen dollars, 01234, and so on,
you can instead of using numbers with your
dollar sign, you can actually give them a name.
And this will allow you to repeat the same
variable in multiple places. So what this looks
like is if I show you, if I trigger this snippet
for our I press enter, notice there's multiple
cursors. Now, so there's a cursor here, here,
here and here. That's because that index that
I probably is what you're going to use it for is
repeated in several places, because we gave it a
name. So if I type in I now it's going to replace
that in every location, which is really nice.
And then I press tab. Well, now if we look back
at the snippet, now we've got our array, tab stop.
And that's used twice to because it's name. So now
we can type in my R, that's going to be the name
of my range. And then I can tab over again. And
then I come down to the end of my snippet. So this
is a really fun way or not, I mean, it is fun,
it is cool. But this is a really practical way
of being able to use that same value in a couple
of different locations. Here's another example of
that one of the things that I use a lot in vanilla
JavaScript is the document dot get element by ID.
And usually typically, the idea that element is
the same name, variable name that I want to call
it inside of JavaScript. So I use this snippet to
grab that value here, and then reference it here
as well. So it's going to use the same thing. So
let's go ahead and trigger this snippet with get
ID. And this is gonna write that whole thing out.
And I'll say, my cool DOM element. And notice
that completes at the end as well. And then I tab
down to the end of the line, because that's where
it ends. Alright, I've got a few in here for
an event listener. And then for me, especially
inside of doing a fetch request, I always have to
do a fetch, and then surrounded with a trycatch,
to handle errors, and then log out the air, get
the data back from the fetch if I want wanted to.
So here's another example of me just thinking
about something that I write all the time,
that would really help me by having a snippet,
I could just do that right in here. So if I run
this snippet, it goes ahead and writes all of
that code for me, I can tell it, I want to get
the data from cool API, COMM And then tab and then
now I've got all that stuff taken care of. Now,
I can just go ahead and handle the response.
So I would say snippets are one of the most
powerful features inside of VS code. Anytime you
see yourself writing a bunch of code over and over
again, and it never really changes you might think
about or a lot of it doesn't change, you might
think about how to use snippets, or defined
snippets inside of your snippets JSON file,
so that you can save yourself some time and effort
later on. Alright, now that we've talked about
settings and themes, and a bunch of different
aspects of VS code, I want to talk about what
previously was an extension if we search in here,
the setting sync extension. Now this is a really
cool extension that came out a while ago where you
could download this extension and it would save
all of the customizations that you've done
inside of VS code into a just inside of GitHub.
And what I mean is it will take all that Your
configurations, your snippets, your shortcuts,
your settings, your extensions, it will take all
of those things and then save them basically in
a file. And then you could use that file or share
that file across different instances of VS code.
So that if I went to another computer opened
up VS code, I could sync my settings sync here.
And then I can have all that stuff ready
to go. So let's let me open up my GitHub.
And then I'll open up my just to show you
what I'm talking about. So I scroll down to
just and then come down here to cloud settings.
Now this is where the setting sync extension
will save all of those things. And if I open this
up, you'll notice I have a few different files.
So I've got cloud settings. This is just for like
metadata of when the last time I updated and what
version I think I was on for that extension. And
then I've got a file here for all the different
extensions that I use. Actually, I think this
is not the correct one. Let me open up this one.
This has all the stuff. So inside of my
extensions that JSON this list out every single
extension that I had installed note of
this, notice this is a pretty big file.
So all of my extensions would be ready to go
all of my custom key bindings, if I had some,
which I do here for Mac, all those custom
key bindings come over the settings that I've
overwritten with VS code, the snippets that
I've created, we talked about a lot of those
snippets here for markdown as well, and Python,
all those things that we've talked about so far,
you want to be able to use on different instances
of VS code if you have to go to another computer.
So up until recently, the setting sync extension
was the way to go to be able to do that. But now,
this is something that is built
into VS code. So let's come in
to settings and I'm going to go Actually, I've
got a tab open here. And if I look in this bottom
left, I've got this icon here for my account.
And this says setting sync is on. And one of the
things I'm going to do to show you how this works
is search for setting sync and then turn this off
and turn this off now. And notice inside of VS
code, this is what you'll see when you open up
your settings window, you'll see this button here
for turn on setting sync. Now what this is going
to do is VS code is basically going to manage
all of this stuff for you behind the scenes.
And make sure that it does the same thing that we
just talked about with this third party extension
built into VS code. So if I click on turn
on setting sync, it asked me what things I
want to actually synchronize. And this is yes,
my settings, my shortcuts, my user snippets,
my extensions, my UI state, so I'll select
all those and I click turn on. And then you'll
either have to log in with your GitHub or your
Microsoft account. Now I've already logged in,
in the past. So this is basically kind of
auto completing that login process, you will
be taken to GitHub have to log in with your GitHub
credentials, and then you'll be brought back here.
And you can see, this says that settings sync
is turned on. If I look at I don't need those
details there. But if I come over to
now, my little window here, and look,
it says that I'm logged in with GitHub, and this
thing is turned on, which is pretty nice. Now we
can also if I look at the search for setting sync
again, as well, and come down to show sync data,
there's a little tab here that will open to show
me the recent synchronization that has happened,
as well as the machines that are synced
with this setting or with these settings. So
if I had VS code on multiple different machines,
I would see in here, which ones are synchronized,
I could refresh this to get a new list, I
could edit this name so that I could be more
specific about which one I'm working with.
And then I can also turn off setting sync
on different ones. So if I didn't want all
of my things to be synced across different
instances of VS code, I could turn that off
on some of them and keep it on on others. And
notice here that in the activity, this shows
me that 35 seconds ago 35 that these things
were updated. And it gives me just a pretty cool
view of what all is going on in here. Alright, so
again, previously, you would have had to jump for
another extension. Now with this built in setting
st you can do this right inside of VS code and not
have to grab a third party extension and be good
to go with making sure that all of your things are
stored across different instances of VS code. Now,
I took a second on here to bring up another
instance of VS code, I've actually got the VS code
regular edition, the stable edition open is
what we've been working with. And then now I've
got open the VS code insiders edition as well.
And this thing has our setting sync turned on
as well. So if we look at the show sync data tab,
you can see it's been doing these synchronizations
and you can see on both sides, there's two
different machines that have been synced.
There's the VS code which one is this let's make
this a little bit bigger. So mac number one that's
the current and there's the insiders Mac over
here. So those things are st and what's cool is if
I come in and search for theme and then go to talk
On my theme, and I want to change it to something.
What crackpot contrast. Sure, let's do that.
And press enter. Notice it changed over here.
And then if I scroll back over, it should change
on this instance of VS code as well. So notice,
it took a few seconds, but that came through
really, really cool. And then I could change this
back to cobalt two. And then this should be able
to now update over here in a few seconds as well.
And you saw that come through. So the settings
extension is super, super powerful. It's really
cool, because now real time you can see these
things change, and make sure that you never
miss any of your settings in VS code. All right,
now I want to take a look at debugging inside of
VS code. This is one of the most powerful and
probably underrated features in VS code. So I'm
going to open up this, this project here, which
is a vanilla HTML, CSS and JavaScript project,
I'm gonna open this one up. And I actually added a
couple of test files here that don't have anything
in them I don't need. So I'm going to delete
those. And then I'm going to open up my HTML file.
And with that go live extension that we talked
about earlier, I'm going to open this with a
live server. So this will open it at Port 5500.
And send me to the index dot HTML page. Now,
what this demo is, is the ability to take a color
and then lighten and darken it. So if I enter in
some sort of color in here, I can then lighten
or it looks like that type that in wrong
should be D. So here's my red color, I can darken
that color, or I can then take that color and
lighten it down to basically a white. So this
is vanilla JavaScript. And I want to show you
how we can actually debug this. So let's open up
our JavaScript file. And let's just look at one of
these functions here, this toggle button. So when
we click on that toggle button, we're applying and
removing some classes to do the styling on here.
So notice the color changes. And then this little
piece in the middle of changes color as well as
moves over to the right or the left, depending on
which side it's toggled to, by look at my debug
tab, this little bug and play button here. And
it's got a run and debug button here. And it's
going to ask me, this is kind of a new feature
inside of VS code where I can now choose where am
I going to run this thing while run it in Chrome.
And then went ahead and created a configuration
in here of where this thing is going to run.
So I'm going to say this is going to run at
5500, because that's where it is running now.
So with that in place, once I press this button,
it's going to open up that application to 5500.
And now debugging is enabled so that I can debug
right inside of VS code. So notice I've got this
menu button up here, none of these things are
really active because we don't have breakpoints
set. And we aren't paused for debugging. So
what this looks like is inside of VS code,
to the left of the numbers, I can now add
breakpoints. So there's a little breakpoint there.
And when I click this toggle button, it should
then trigger that breakpoint inside of VS code.
So we'll click this. Now it goes away from
Chrome comes over to VS code and hits right at
that breakpoint. Now, if you're new to debugging,
this may be a lot. But the alternative to this is
typically people will just kind of do console
log statements instead of true debugging. But
true debugging is incredibly powerful. So with
this thing, pause at this line. Now some of these
buttons here are enabled. So I can play and this
will just say Alright, go ahead and continue as
you were and it goes to dark. And now let's click
it again. Instead of playing, we can come down.
And we can step over. So we can go through
line by line and see what's going on notice
that skip that else. And then now that we're
at a function that we have this reset function
that comes down here, and instead of skipping over
that line, we can actually step into so step into
will go inside of that function and go through
or allow us to go through line by line here. So
I could go through and go line by line. And then I
could continue when I was reading. But one of the
things I want to show you is that you can inspect
variables in here. So if we look at our script,
actually, I can see all of the different elements
that I have created inside of my JavaScript inside
of this script inside of this JavaScript file.
So if I look for this input color, for example,
I can scroll down. And I can see the input color,
and it shows me what selector that thing is. And
then I can look at, here's all the different
properties and functions associated with that.
So you can see I've got all of these in here,
as well as the functions that I've created. So
I can inspect all of these variables. And
then you can choose one of those variables
and tell it to watch for that thing. So if I say,
watch for the toggle button, here's my toggle
button. And if I click the play in here, and then
I click this again, I come back to my debugging.
And then I click this toggle again. Now it's going
to show me right off here since I'm watching for
this variable. Now I see it right now. And I can
see that it doesn't have the class of toggled
so I'll go ahead and play And then if I
come back and I toggle this thing again,
now we should see that it has the class of
toggle. So this is actually an interesting way
to I could check for DOM elements
to see if classes are being applied.
As opposed to let me make sure I play this again,
as opposed to coming into inspect. And then going
into the element itself. And looking inside
of there, I can see this inside of my watch.
So overall, debugging in vs. Code is very
powerful. It's one of those features that
is highly underrated and very, very useful
for you. So that is an example of debugging
kind of vanilla JavaScript, I also want to show
you an example of debugging something in Node
as well. Alright, so I've got a new application
open. This is designed and built a chat app with
socket IO and node j s. So you can actually grab
this code on GitHub if you're interested. And
there is a video series on YouTube on how to
build this as well. But with this stuff here,
I made sure to install the packages and I CD into
my part eight directory, which is really where I
want to be because that's the final step of this
project. So if I open up the debug tab here,
and let me make sure that I can open this server
j s, because it told me I needed to open up a
JavaScript file. And then I come to debug and
let's say run and debug. And then I'll click node,
I didn't really have to do anything extra. But
now this thing is ready to go. And if we open
up our browser to localhost 3000, we should
see now this application is up and running.
And it actually works. So this thing is running
our application. Now we should be able to set a
debug point and do the same sort of thing like we
did before. So let's do a debug breakpoint on the
message handler. So when a message actually
comes through, let's set a breakpoint. And
let's trigger it and then come back over
here. So let's try to type out a message.
Hey, this is James, and press send this now hit
that breakpoint. And we can do the same things we
did before look at variables that watches didn't
talk about this. But you can see the call stack.
This shows you the history of the functions that
were calling. And then I had the ability to step
in step through all those sort of things as
well as just go ahead and click the play,
and it will go ahead and send that message.
So just wanted to add on here a small example
of what it's like to debug an application
that uses No, not just fill JavaScript.
But the cool thing is that VS code makes
that really easy for you regardless.
All right, we've mentioned this a few
times. But VS code has a built in Terminal,
you actually seen this a little bit right inside
of VS code that I want to talk about as well.
So I want to say that a lot of our some people
don't prefer to use the built in Terminal in VS
code, they prefer to have a separate window for
their terminal, I'll tell you that my personal
preference is that I really enjoy having the
terminal built right into VS code. So that I
can do everything that I need to in my editor
and not have to worry about other applications.
So as you would probably expects, you can do
everything inside of this terminal that you would
in your regular terminal. So I use an application
called hyper, that's what I use for my terminal.
And if you're on Mac, you'll have like the built
in Mac terminal, if you're on Windows you might
have might have PowerShell, or Command Prompt
or Git Bash or things like that. But this is my
terminal. And it uses z sh instead of bash. So z
sh is actually the default shell on my computer.
So yours will pick up your default shell and
I think this is z sh has probably become the
default shell on Mac in the last couple of months.
But regardless, you'll see which shell you have
here to be able to use. And you can select
your default one if you need to change it.
But this is going to open up and have basically
the same experience that you would have inside
of your regular terminal, which is really, really
nice. Now a couple of things I want to show you
on here is you can have multiple instances of your
terminal, you can set them side by side, which is
kind of cool. I don't really use this myself. And
the reason is that I end up having multiple tabs
inside of my terminal but not side by side.
So what I mean is let me kill this one.
If I do the plus over here, this is going to
do a new tab. So you can see now I have this
drop down between one and to. And so this is
how I usually work with mine. But then I did
some shortcuts on here to customize this and
make this a little bit easier to work with.
So I customized my shortcuts to be able to use
the same way I would use up here. If I have two
different files that control and tab to be able
to toggle through them. I have that set up as a
custom shortcut for my terminal as well. So now I
can tab through these and not have to worry about
losing out on space by having them side by side.
But if you have enough space on your computer,
and it seems to work out, well you can do a split
and you can also have multiple of these 2345
you can kind of get crazy with this and it's
probably not very practical at that point.
But it's something that you can do. And then
you also have this little button to go ahead and
expand this all the way up which is kind of nice.
There's also control and command and Up or Down,
we'll kind of increase the size of this or
decrease the size of this by a little bit to make
it a little bit bigger or a little bit smaller. So
I happen to use that one a lot as well. Now you'll
notice on this delete over here, if I hovered
on kill terminal, it says command W, that's not
a built in command, that's one that I customized
for my experience as well. That way it will match
the command w or Ctrl w on windows that I use
to close files up here, I can close tabs just
the same inside of my terminal. So again, I've
done some customization to make sure that this
works exactly how I would expect. And the other
thing I think you should know, is that control
until they will toggle open this terminal. So we
mentioned early on that I use Command or Control
B to close that side panel, I also do Ctrl until
they to open and close the terminal. That way,
I can have a lot of space for my code. If I need
the terminal, I do control until day. And then
if I need the sidebar, I do command B, getting
used to those shortcuts is really, really useful.
All right, and then if I come into the settings
in here, as well, you notice we have lots of
settings or a handful of settings for the terminal
as well. Alright, so if we search terminal, and
then I'm going to click on the terminal category
here. Alright, if I scroll down, and start to look
at some of the settings associated with terminal,
keep scrolling down, let's get to some of the fun
ones. One, you can customize what your shell
is. So if you want to customize that, based on
the operating system that you're on, you can do
that. So let's look at there's a cursor style,
so we can have the block or a line. And notice
this becomes a lot thinner, you can have a cursor
width. So I could change this and make this a lot
bigger five. Alright, so and I think actually, the
one is kind of interesting. You can also have this
cursor blink. So similar to how we had our cursor
acting inside of our code. Now this thing
will blink when I have it focused on, I'm
going to scroll down and grab a few more of these
settings. You can change your font, family and
font in here. And actually I need to update this
to Cascadia code. Because I had used in this may
need to go inside of quotes, because I had used
fear code in the past. And now I'm using Cascadia
code, although I think I'm getting a little bit
of an odd thing there. So let's check back to
fear code. And that goes away. So I'll just leave
here code there, you can change the font. So if
you wanted the font size in your terminal to be
a little bit bit bigger or smaller, you could
do that as well. So very similar to how you do
inside of regular checks, font weight of bold,
line height, letter spacing, if I did a 10 for
letter spacing, this will space things out a lot,
probably not what we want. But you get the ability
to customize those things right inside of here,
which is actually pretty nice. And I think
there is a terminal position or location,
default location. So this, this controls the
default location of the panel there, which
includes the terminal, the debug button,
and so on. And this can either be at the
bottom right or left of the workbench. So
if you wanted to put this on either side,
you could do that as well. And it looks like we've
still got our debugging session up. So I'm gonna
go ahead and kill that. So anyway, inside of
your built in Terminal one, I would recommend
knowing how to toggle that open and close. So you
only have it open when you need it. Know that you
can create multiple instances of your terminal by
adding the plus or by setting them side by side,
you can close them, you can make this
fullscreen close that back down here.
And once you get used to kind of navigating
that and working with it alongside of your code,
I think you'll really really enjoy it the way
that I do. Alright, so we've got our debugging
section is out of the way, we've got the built
in Terminal out of the way. Now, let's take a
look at some of the Git integration. So inside of
here, we've got the source control tab. And this
is actually telling me that I've already got
a file that has changed. So let's open up I'm
gonna open up a different project. Let's open up
a recent let's go back to that quick colors one.
And yes, this is actually asking me if I want to
kill a terminal session. Yes, I'm okay with that.
And let's come back in here. And notice that
this part is red, if I do a git, or not red,
but yellow, if I do a git status, notice,
it's telling me that some things have changed.
So all the things that I could do down here, so
if I did a git init. And actually, maybe that's
worth doing. So let's go back out here. Let's go
into our delete, delete me folder. And let's do a
make dir of test Git. And then I'm going to open
that thing up. So I'm going to open up the test,
test kit. And let's just see this inside of VS
code. So what I would probably do if I wanted
this to be a git repository is I would run a git
init command. Well, in VS code, you can actually
do that right inside of here. So if I come to the
source control, it says Do I want to initialize
this repository? Yeah, let's go ahead and do that.
And that will basically run this Git init command.
So then I could come in and add a file, so
test dot HTML or something and use our bang
to get a, an HTML file. And so I would
come into the terminal run a git status,
I would see that this file needs to be added,
I would do git add test, HTML, git commit,
and so on. But I could come in and see this
as well. And notice that not only do I have
the ability to stage these changes, or add them,
I also have the ability to add a commit message
and revert this file. If we look at this kind
of backward squirrely arrow, I can discard those
changes, as well as open the file and see the
differences. And this is really cool. So let's
do a couple of things. Let's go ahead and stage
this file. And then we'll go ahead and commit this
and say added test dot html. And do the checkbox
here. Alright, so that thing has been added. Now,
let's add in a title, working with Git. And
we'll see that this file has changed again.
And now notice, if I click on this, I see a very
cool diff to show me exactly what's changed. So
VS code, I think, is one of the best diff
tools, being able to see the differences
visually and different in files that have changed
VS code is a great way of just kind of laying
these out and showing you what's changed, which
I think is really neat. So from there, I could
go through that same process, let's say just
thing and then updated the test dot html file.
Alright, so with that in place, I'll
click the check. And we're good to go.
Now, one other thing that VS code allows you to
do now that they are Microsoft bought GitHub,
there's even better integration here, where I
don't have this actually created in a repository.
I don't have this created as an actual repository
in GitHub. So one of the things that I can do is
scroll down to the Publish to GitHub command,
this is really neat, because right here,
I can say publish to GitHub, a Can I can choose
between a private and a public repository.
So if I do a public repository, it's asking me
which file should be in there, my index or my test
HTML? Yes. And this is going to say published to
GitHub. It's already published. This is a GitHub
repository. If I come over to my GitHub now, and
search in my repositories, let's pull up the full
list of repositories here. Now we should see this
test to get now this has always been or has been,
for me in the past an issue where I would have to
come in to GitHub, create the repository, and then
go through the steps. Now, these things are taken
care of from inside of VS code. So this repository
is created. Now I can push this code to that
repository. And I guess we need to add our remote
and we'll add the remote from GitHub. And then
we'll choose this repository that we just created.
And we'll name this as origin. And that should
go ahead and push all that code out all that
code is just one file, but push that file out
to. And now if we refresh that repository,
we see that stuff got added up here. So from
inside of VS code, I can do my basic Git workflow.
And then I can also create repositories
inside of GitHub, instead of having to go
to GitHub directly. This is really, really
powerful. And I want to scroll back over to
my project here. If we look at I've got some
things that have changed, I've got a launch JSON,
this is for that debugging stuff that we checked
out. And then I've made some changes. If we scroll
down, and I can look at these individually, if I
wanted to, I could scroll up and see the app CSS,
see the things that have changed there as well.
I'm not going to do anything with those changes,
because I don't need to right now. But you have
the full ability to do all the things that you're
used to add commit push clone poll, you can check
out different branches. You can see I've got the
branch selected here, I can create a new branch,
I can choose a different one, if I wanted to
do all that stuff right inside of VS code. Now,
one thing I do want to show you on top of that
is VS code has some amazing built in support for
git, but it also has extensions that can help you
as well. And get lends to me is the most powerful
extension out there. You can look at let's open a
file and see this. So if I open that app j s, and
then open up the Git lens extension, I can see
the File History. So what the different commits
were, if I select a line, I can see the history
based on that line and the different commits
that were made with that. I can look at how many
different branches and contributors and remotes
and stashes and tags and things that I have.
Also, if you look at this text over here, that is
get blamed text, which comes from this extension,
which will show me that I edited this file
three months ago or this line three months ago,
and a commit that had refactoring code as the
commit. And so not only does it show you in line
over here, if you hover on that, now you get this
extra detail and you can go and actually click on
the commit, click on the person if I wanted to.
And it opened up actually Open up an email on
another monitor. But I can see a lot of different
information about the commits the history,
I can see the same thing down here. And then I get
lots of options to open those files to show the
commit, and the search commits view, to open the
commit, and GitHub, all these different things.
This is by far, the most powerful extension
for working with Git inside of VS code,
I highly recommend checking it out. And then on
top of that, on top of already the really amazing
built in features inside of VS code. Alright,
the last thing I want to show you is one of the
coolest and most powerful features in VS code, and
that is the live share extension. So let's come to
extensions. And let's search for live share. And
I think you'll be blown away if you've never seen
this before, of what it does. What this does is
it allows me to share my code live with someone
so that we can have like a live peer programming
session remotely, we could be across the world,
we could share code, we could talk through code,
we could do all these things, right with this live
share extension inside of VS code. So you want
to make sure you have that extension installed.
And then I'll type in the command palette, live
share. And I'm going to scroll down to find the
start collaboration session. So when I do that,
I'll need to login with GitHub. I'm already logged
in, in this case, so I can just copy this link,
so it copies it for me or I can copy it again.
And I'm going to come over to my other instance of
VS code. And I'm going to trigger this with live
share join collaboration session. So let's join
this. And I'll need to sign in here as well. So
I'll sign in with my GitHub account with my jamesy
quick GitHub, I'll go ahead and authorize that
thing. You'll need to go through this process as
well. It'll redirect me back to VS code. And I
say, all right, that's good to go. And then I need
to actually trigger this again. So it actually
grabbed here is the session that I'm trying to
join. I'm pasting this from this other instance
of VS code over here, the one that I started it
on. And so I'll press enter in here. And active
terminal session. Yes, I'll kill it, I actually
want to turn that off. So let's search for
terminal kill. VS code is going to need some
permissions on my computer to make this work.
I also want to change that setting for the
terminal to not prompt. Yeah, confirm on
exit. So I want to turn that off. Okay. Now, you
can see I didn't have this quit colors project
open on this side, it was only open. On the other
instance of VS code. Let me grab that. So here,
here the code is and I can toggle around, I can
move my cursor. And notice that inside of here,
this is my cursor on the insiders edition. And
here's the cursor from the person in this case,
this instance that created the share session. So
I can see this real time. And I can follow the
person as they navigate through code. So if I open
up a new file, this will can if I choose Open up
the new file here as well. And the way that works
is with this pin. So if I use this pin, I can
follow this person around as they scroll through
code and change files. Notice that scrolling and
changing files, and I'm not even doing anything.
So one person could kind of teach and show and
walk through code. While the other person just
follows you could turn that off, you could
both work on code at the same time, you can share
a terminal, you can do all sorts of things with VS
code, live share. This is such a cool extension to
have enabled for you to do peer programming with
someone across the world or someone that's maybe
on the same computer as I'm doing in this demo.
Regardless of how you use it. This is one of the
coolest and most powerful features inside of VS
code. And you should definitely check it out. It's
very useful for being able to do peer debugging or
code review sessions. It's flat out amazing.
Alright, I just want to do a quick recap here
and just kind of talk about how I think and most
or Many people think that VS code is the best,
the most popular, the most powerful editor for
lots of different things, but specifically for web
development is where it will really really shine.
We covered lots of different features of VS code,
we looked at downloading the stable edition, the
insiders edition and the difference between those
two, we looked at the layout and how to customize
it and really optimize the view in VS code for
you as a developer so that you can write code as
fast as possible. Another thing we talked about
getting into speed is how to use those shortcuts,
you want to keep your hands off of the mouse as
much as possible. Keep your hands on the keyboard.
So learning those shortcuts in VS code is really,
really crucial. Knowing how to toggle open your
menu bars and how to navigate texts quickly
and shortcuts for opening and closing and saving
files and things like that is really, really going
to save you a ton of time. And then we started to
get into a lot of the customization aspects of VS
code. And there are lots of ways to customize it,
which is my favorite thing about VS code. It's
built with electron. It's built with HTML, CSS and
JavaScript so you can make changes and immediately
See those things take place. So some of the
things we looked at are just some of your built
in settings, things like your font family, I use
Cascadia j. s, I used to use fear code, you can
get those free on GitHub if you search for them
and install them. And then I use font ligatures,
to be able to have those fancy characters for
arrows and different things like that. Looked
at font size and zoom size. And there's a ton of
different features or settings in VS code that
you can customize. And the cool thing is they make
it really easy for you to customize them as well.
We also looked at customizing your key maps, of
being able to for you to define what you want
your shortcuts to be. So I think VS code has a lot
of great built in shortcuts. But if you have ways
that you want to customize that, you can certainly
do that too. In addition to that, once we get
into extensions, you see that they have key map
extensions that you can download and port and key
maps from other editors like sublime, or Notepad
or things like that, so that you can keep those
shortcuts that you're used to. And then we covered
a list of really useful extensions, ones that
I use every day, the live server extension is
one that I do literally use almost every day,
the advanced new file extension, the color, pair,
the color, the bracket, pair colorizer, extension,
all of these that we walk through are really
great. They're ones that I use all the time.
We looked at things I use the cobalt to theme,
there's Winter is coming. And there's night owl by
Sarah dresner. There's a ton you can just search
for dreams or dreams, themes and really customize
those to make them your own. And then we got into
some of the deeper features in VS code, being able
to do debugging right inside of your editor not
having to go to the browser doing breakpoints
and walking through files. We did that in vanilla
JavaScript or front end JavaScript, as well as
node VS code just makes this really, really easy.
And then we moved on to source control integration
of or working with Git inside of VS code. It's got
great built in tools for working with repositories
locally for working with remote repositories in
GitHub. And then we talked about the get lens
extension on top of that, to really supercharge
your Git workflow. And then lastly, we took a
look at the live share extension, which allows you
to write code real time or share code real time or
walkthrough code real time with someone across the
world wherever they are. In the same editor. You
can see each other's cursor, you can follow each
other around stuff like that. So that is really,
really impactful for code reviews and teaching
and learning, working with someone on code. So
all in all VS code is the best editor that's out
there for web development and for a lot of things.
I highly recommend it. I hope this Crash Course
helps and thanks for checking out the video.